you
I'm here in Barcelona as part of a
columbia alumni event it's my very first
event so I figured why not do it a big I
live in Amsterdam and I thought this
week great opportunity to really feel
connected to the Columbia community in
Europe and in the world with many of our
programs we want to provide an
intellectual opportunity as well as a
social networking or career networking
opportunity Barcelona is very well known
for its artistic work but it was a
fantastic time to come with Colombia
because it open up some doors that
normally coming along we will not see
it's a beautiful time of year to be here
I think intellectually it's very
enriching when I looked at the schedule
I saw that there were going to be lots
of museum trips and walking tours but I
didn't really understand was that these
would be led by professors who were very
knowledgeable in the subject I really
feel lucky to be the beneficiary of so
much intelligence has gone into the
planning I'd known of Gowdy and seen his
work in photographs but I didn't think I
would have such a visceral reaction
i unexpectedly fell in love with it
we went to Sacramento for the year when
a good better one of the greatest
architectures work in Barcelona the
Cathedral I'm finished yet when we see
his real work and so how amazing it is
and how inviting it is it was revealed
the whole trip viewing amazing art
tasting amazing foods and with excellent
wines and having interesting
conversation my favorite moments are
part was jazz a casa booster it was just
a great environment we had a great
conversation across different
generations of Columbia
walking through the old quarter of the
city and hearing from an architecture
and preservation professor about the
meaning of what they were saying not
just a tour guide colorful site I hadn't
really looked at the creation of this
part of the town as a sort of a
retelling of history doing it with other
people who have a genuine appetite for
ideas and for continuing to learn the
parties have been wonderful I've met
many new people one is really where I
grew up and where I spent my formative
years and where I became the person that
I am today and I wanted to stay
connected to that period of my life
it's a very welcome connection and I
think to myself how is I so smart took
too long to Columbia it's a pleasure to
you show and to share my CD with
Columbia Lunae the CIA is Barcelona with
CAA is past the lunar the CAA is
Barcelona the TA is Barcelona
you